[Música]
hora de hablar de economía aquí en
directo América de France 24 por ello me
acompaña en el estudio mi compañero
Jorge Hurtado Jorge bienvenido vamos a
iniciar en Europa porque la presidenta
del Banco Central europeo se pronunció
sobre los tipos de interés Así es bueno
el Banco Central europeo comenzó a subir
los tipos de interés desde julio del año
pasado en siete ocasiones lo ha hecho y
lo ha llevado hasta el 3,75% ahora la
presidenta del Banco Central dejó Claro
que todavía tienen camino para llevarlos
a niveles suficientemente restrictivos
en Europa la combinación de una política
monetaria más restrictiva y también la
inflación seguiría pesando sobre la
estabilidad financiera de la zona del
euro según un reciente informe
presentado por el banco aunque las
condiciones económicas del eurozona
mejoraron un poco y sus bancos resisten
a la crisis bancaria de Estados Unidos
el panorama podría cambiar drásticamente
esto si los fondos de inversión se ven
obligados a vender activos para mejorar
la liquidez según advirtió este
comunicado del banco el informe también
dice que los tipos de interés la
inflación y las en ciertas condiciones
de la economía global seguirían
afectando a las empresas los hogares Y
los gobiernos Jorge a partir de este
viernes el Banco Mundial va a tener un
nuevo presidente de quién se trata
hablamos de allá y Banga es un
exdirector general de mastercard y será
presidente del Banco Mundial por los
próximos 5 años el hombre de 63 años
nació en India Busca renovar esa entidad
crediticia para hacer frente al cambio
climático y otras crisis mundiales a
finales de febrero el presidente de
Estados Unidos Joe biden lo propuso para
el puesto y llegará a la presidencia del
banco luego de ser el único aspirante a
sustituir al jefe saliente David malpase
según biden banda es un líder renovador
que encaminará al banco para enfrentar
desafíos como el cambio climático los
conflictos o incluso futuras pandemias
su nombramiento se debe a su carrera y
vínculos con el sector privado y también
su cercanía a los mercados emergentes
tradicionalmente el Banco Mundial ha
sido dirigido por estadounidenses desde
su fundación Mientras que el fondo
monetario internacional es dirigido por
europeos Bueno vamos a cambiar de tema
en Pakistán Pakistán no se libra de esta
inflación alta que están viviendo varios
países del mundo y Es que allí el índice
de precios alcanzó el
37,97% anual en mayo Sí de hecho los
alimentos no perecederos y el transporte
subieron más del 50% respecto hace un
año el país se encuentra al borde del
colapso económico mientras negocian con
organismos fondos para un rescate
económico el país sufre los efectos de
años de mala gestión financiera agravada
por una crisis energética mundial y
devastadora sin inundaciones que
sumergieron un tercio de ese país en el
2022 sin mencionar por supuesto la
incertidumbre política que existe las
negociaciones para desbloquear parte de
ese préstamo de 6.500 millones de
dólares acordado con el fondo monetario
internacional lleva meses sin ningún
tipo de avances vamos a cambiar de
latitud vamos a México porque las
remesas aumentaron un 10,1% entre enero
y abril de 2023 si en el primer
trimestre de este año México recibió
18.974 millones de dólares de sus
ciudadanos residentes en el extranjero
según datos del banco de México la cifra
es 10,1% más respecto al mismo periodo
del año anterior con ello México superó
en en 1700 millones de dólares los
17.230 millones recibidos en los
primeros cuatro meses del 2022 si lo
vemos por mes solo en abril México captó
5 mil millones de dólares en remesas un
avance interanual del
6,3%, las remesas en ese país llevan 36
meses ya con incrementos interanuales
consecutivos y representan la principal
fuente de ingresos externos para ese
país en 2022 México recibió o anotó un
récord en remesas de
58.497 millones de dólares Un aumento
del 13, ciento respecto de 2021 las
remesas representan cerca del 4% del pib
de ese país según un cálculo del banco
BBVA Jorge vamos a cerrar con Los
indicadores económicos de la jornada
empezamos en Wall Street que cerró al
alza por las señales de ralentización de
la presión salarial sobre la inflación
esto generó mayores esperanzas de que la
reserva Federal o al Banco Central de
ese país haga una pausa en la subida de
los tipos de interés dentro de dos
semanas sumado también al avance del
acuerdo del techo de la deuda en Europa
las bolsas se recuperaron por los datos
de inflación que se sumaron al debate
sobre la necesidad de Nueva subidas de
los tipos de interés más allá de este
mes en América Latina el índice merval
de la bolsa de comercio de Buenos Aires
cerró con un alza del 3,30% tras dos
ruedas consecutivas en negativo porque
pues a usted muchas gracias por esta
información económica quédese con
nosotros que ya